hey guys it was docked over the ninth my
name is Jess Mattel and you're tuned
into games what news Marcus oft have
some words to say to those of you sore
about the xbox one's lack of backwards
compatibility head of Xbox bill Spencer
talk to be in a circle podcast about the
feature saying back compat is always a
hot topic at the turn of a generation
and I get why especially on xbox 360 so
many people bought so much digital
content and it means that a lot of us
we're holding on to our 360s I get the
question I totally respect the question
there's nothing I can say about it right
now but I'll just say I hear you I
definitely hear you and I'll continue to
try to work to build something that can
help people out currently the wii u is
the early new gen console to enable
backwards compatibility although sony's
playstation now streaming service can
stream ps3 games onto the ps4 the widget
ave CD Projekt RED have responded to
claims that they've been crunching their
developers for over a year to help deal
with development issues a user on NeoGAF
who had been vetted and cleared as an
insider with knowledge of the studio
said that CD Projekt RED PR was over
hyping a game that doesn't exist while
the team is in constant crunch time that
is working and unreasonable and
unhealthy amount of the time on
development in response a spokesperson
from CD Projekt RED said that the
gameplay videos speak to the quality of
the game the studio did not opt to apply
for comment on the crunching accusation
Ubisoft have done their best to enrage
the masses today by saying who cares
about resolution if the game looks
gorgeous Assassin's Creed unity world
level design director Nicola gaha told
TechRadar they opted for 30 frames per
second instead of 60 because 60 looked
weird and unnatural likening it to Peter
Jackson's Hobbit films ya ha said he
thinks the industry will end up backing
off 60 frames per second because it's
difficult to achieve and not all that
good in terms of rendering quality of
the image AC unit e creative director
Alex mansio went on to say 60 is real
good for shooter action adventure not so
much it actually feels better for people
when it's at that 30 frames per second
it also lets us push the limits of
everything to the maximum it's like when
people start asking about resolution is
it the number or the quality of the
pixels that you want if the game looks
gorgeous who cares about the number
after your question of the day let me
pose you guys that same question do you
care about the numbers if the game looks
gorgeous if you're after more newsy bits
and pieces we've got stories on the
resolution for the evil within and
uncharted 4 on site that is it from me
today tomorrow i have my top 5 stories
of the whole gaming week so be sure to
check back with me then